i got gourd by boar here and i got a
missing tendon here too so this hand
ain't well either
how many animals have you been bitten by
uh let me see
four different types of shark
uh
two types of rattlesnake pygmy and
western diamondback
and uh alligator once in the back and
wild boar right here
in the leg you got my leg i got a hole
in my leg and i hold here the wall board
the bullet was coming out like this
so yeah yeah walmart is another bad
animal to mess with you know i mean it
really they're smart
and they will mess you up you get the
right boar
it'll put you in the hospital if not
kill you jesus how many animals have you
been bitten by steve we used to keep a
list of uh of animals that but our list
wasn't as because manny only manny's
list has higher standards than ours
but i i
i keep i keep lists of movies i've seen
in different countries
you guys keep track of animals that have
bitten you in different countries it's
called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on amazon and
type in stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on amazon and buy
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah yeah dude